repasamos los titulares en la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de un
rosa félix luna es feliz inicio de
semana para usted nosotros vamos a
comenzar entonces hablando en áfrica
para hablar de este proceso de
magnicidio de thomas sankara que se abra
hoy en burkina faso buenos dias raúl así
es nos hemos querido fijar en este medio
africano región áfrica que califica este
proceso de histórico así se titula rosa
asesinato de thomas sankara el histórico
proceso que se abre en uagadugú eso es
recordemos este medio está siendo un
live es decir este tipo de seguimiento
que hacen pues muy a menudo los
periódicos en los que van actualizando a
cada momento la que está siendo pues la
noticia más destacada y pues destaca que
el magnicidio del que fue presidente
entre
1983 y 1987 recordemos empieza a
juzgarse hoy más de 30 años después en
la capital de burkina faso y destaca un
poco lo que comentábamos también en los
noticieros no entre los 14 acusados las
dos grandes ausencias por un lado el qué
pues también fue el director del comando
que asesinó a campar ahí a sus 12
colaboradores no el cazando que
supuestamente se encuentra en costa de
marfil pero donde 100% está confirmado
que está en costa de marfil es blaise
campaoré el que asumió la presidencia
luego del magnicidio que fue presidente
durante 27 años hasta ser depuesto en
2014 por un levantamiento popular y
precisamente destaca este medio que fue
durante durante estos 27 años que no se
inició el proceso de magnicidio
precisamente no pues porque campaoré lo
impidió y destaca también lo que
comentábamos en los noticieros y es como
en este juicio en particular no se no se
va a juzgar la supuesta injerencia
extranjera en el caso del magnicidio no
de este líder tan incómodo por ser pues
una referencia de la izquierda
panafricanista del antiimperialismo del
anticolonialismo y casos como esa la
potencial de injerencia de potencias
como francia pues van a quedar fuera de
la causa del momento así es rosa pues
dejamos tema aula nos vamos al otro
extremo del planeta para hablar del
aumento de la atención entre beijing y
taipei y le vamos a abarcar con dos
periódicos en el taipei times que dice
la presidenta promete defender la
soberanía y luego el lado de china el
'global times' el discurso de saif del
doble 10 es una performance
minuciosamente coreografiada dice eso es
raúl vamos a como comentabas ver la
diferencia de como abordan el discurso
de ayer día nacional de taiwán por eso
se llama doble' 10 10 de octubre de la
de la presidenta no y empezamos en
taipei donde dicen sign wen la
presidenta de taiwán prometió defender
la democracia y la soberanía no de la de
la isla de taiwán y citan pues algunos a
algunas partes del que fue su discurso
déjame leerte una en concreto
continuaremos reforzando nuestra defensa
nacional y nuestra determinación de
defendernos para evitar que nadie fuerce
a taiwán a emprender el camino que china
nos impone y es que recordemos que esta
celebración tuvo lugar en medio de lo
que distintos analistas califican como
el mayor aumento de las tensiones entre
beijing y taipei de las últimas décadas
y precisamente por esto la presidenta de
taiwán intenta un poco aumentar su
retórica bélica así es rosa y ahora ama
entonces con él el 'global times' en
china eso es y el 'global times' de
hecho es pues hace una editorial como
suele hacer este medio chino escrito en
inglés alineado completamente con la
línea del partido comunista chino y
básicamente empezando el 'global times'
evidentemente califica hay un web de
presidente del líder de la región de
taiwán como no podría ser de otra forma
dice está intentando convencer a sus
aliados como a estados unidos de que
prometan no de cara a la galería' la
defensa de taiwán sin embargo asegura
eeuu nunca va a reconocer oficialmente a
taiwán como estado soberano y a
abandonar la política de una sola china
dice todo esto están siendo juegos de
taiwán que no van a revertir la
tendencia histórica de acá con una
reunificación de china y dice
precisamente es muy claro a medida que
aumenta la influencia global de china y
su potencia en el tablero internacional
el mundo ve cada vez más cerca la
reunificación y taiwán precisamente no
toda esta retórica viene por este miedo
terminamos ahora en eeuu pero con una
portada del país dice un trágico cuento
de hadas en la de las redes sociales
desaparición y muerte de gabi apetito
polémico caso en eeuu eso es raúl pues a
quien no le hemos dado mucho seguimiento
pero ha sido un tema súper mediatizado
en eeuu lo contextualizamos rápidamente
para luego fijarnos en lo que maría
antonia sánchez vallejo esta periodista
del país nos quiere comentar recordemos
gaby apetito es una influencer
instagramers estadounidense que bueno
pues de estilo de vida etcétera que
estaba de viaje con su prometido bryant
laundry a través del país en una
autocaravana es el viaje lo emprendieron
en julio y a mediados de agosto pues
gabi apetito desapareció varian laundry
regresó al sin su prometida semanas
después se encontró el cadáver de
apetito y bryant laundry de su prometido
está la fuga un caso de desaparición en
el que se le ha dado muchísima cobertura
en eeuu y precisamente esto es lo que
quiere señalar maría antonia sánchez
vallejo esta periodista del país por dos
principales razones dice por un lado por
como las redes sociales no algo que
hemos venido comentando tanto la semana
pasada con el tema de facebook pues
pueden ocultar pues son muchos problemas
entre ellos pues un supuesto caso de lo
que podría ser violencia de género
porque no hace falta decir que su
prometido es el principal sospechoso del
homicidio y por otro lado dice también
lo que se califica de síndrome de la
mujer blanca desaparecida es un término
acuñado por gwen ifill una periodista
afroestadounidense que denuncia
precisamente como las desapariciones de
mujeres blancas y de clases
privilegiadas centran muchísimo más la
atención mediática que el resto de casos
de desapariciones de personas realizadas
dice esto es un privilegio de raza
incluso en la desgracia lamentable esta
situación no rosa muchísimas gracias
como siempre por todos los titulares de
la prensa internacionales juegos mañana
con más ahora vamos con nuestro invitado
del día
[Música]